he was the heart of perhaps the greatest
television drama of all time but that
hasn't translated to big-screen stardom
in a recent sit-down with vulture Aaron
Paul star of the AMC TV series Breaking
Bad and its upcoming sequel film el
camino a Breaking Bad movie offered a
little insight as to why he hasn't
popped up more often in feature films
and why he's not likely to in the future
Paul recalled that in the wake of a wild
popularity of Breaking Bad and his
subsequent stardom he was eager to
parlay his success into starring roles
and other projects whether on the big
screen or small and he was in no way
hurting for opportunities he confessed
I was so spoiled at the height of
Breaking Bad I was being offered
everything after Breaking Bad ended in
2013 he starred in several smaller
independent features though they did
little to raise his profile
Paul's chance to make a splash in a big
expensive blockbuster came his way in
2014 when he appeared in the lead role
in the video game adaptation need for
speed unfortunately the flick failed to
jumpstart Paul's movie career it
underperformed at the box office and was
savaged by critics and his next big
studio effort the Ridley Scott helped
biblical epic Exodus gods and Kings
didn't fare much better
it's simply seen that Paul's acting
style all barely contained the motion
with worlds of subtext plainly visible
and his soulful expressive eyes was much
better suited for the small screen and
he also appeared to thrive the most when
his characters were given the room to
breathe and grow afforded by the serial
format his next television efforts in
the lead role in the Hulu original
series the path drew critical accolades
for his performance but the creative
minds behind the series weren't quite as
focused as those responsible for
Breaking Bad and Hulu axed the show
after three seasons Paul continued to
surface in indie features and smaller
major studio productions but he
continually ran up against the same
problem casting directors who seemed to
think that they were securing the
services of Jesse Pinkman rather than
Aaron Paul Exhibit A the 2016 Dwayne
Johnson Kevin Hart comedy central
intelligence in which Paul's character
makes frequent use of a certain five
letter B word with which Pinkman was
known to pepper every other sentence
this is my own private domicile and it
will not be harassed eventually the
phone calls from the big studios became
fewer and further between due to the
perception that Paul couldn't carry a
major Hollywood production on xone the
actor explained you do one commercial
film that's not the success they think
it's going to be and you're damned
fortunately Paul had found plenty of
space to flex his creative muscles as
the voice of the eternally cheerful yet
deceptively complex Todd Chavez on the
Netflix animated series Bojack horseman
and roles in smaller features such as
act Whedon's 2016 come and find me and
jake scott's 2018 drama american woman
have kept him busy we'll be seeing him
on the small screen early and often in
the months to come
starting with a triumphant return to his
signature role in el camino a Breaking
Bad movie an opportunity which presented
itself directly after his agent had
discouraged him for taking a role in a
feature that went on to become quote a
monster monster hit Paul declined to
name set feature Paul said of that
experience there were some big thorns in
my side that I had to let go my wife
knew all of this was going on so when I
told her what Breaking Bad creator Vince
Gilligan wanted to do she threw her arms
around me she knew it was an opportunity
for me to spread my wings again Breaking
Bad fans absolutely cannot wait to see
Paul saddle up as Jesse Pinkman one more
time and while it's almost certainly the
last we'll ever see a Pinkman we're
going to be seen plenty appalled he can
currently be seen in one of those small
indie thrillers the parts you lose as a
violent fugitive who forges an unlikely
friendship with a depth youngster but he
seems most excited about his involvement
in the upcoming third season of HBO's
Westworld in which he'll play a role
that shrouded in secrecy as far as
big-budget features are concerned
however Paul appears to have had his
fill of that world he said I can't live
with that pressure on me nor will I I'm
happy we can only hope that Pinkman will
be able to say the same at the
conclusion of his story El Camino a
Breaking Bad movie premieres on Netflix
on October 11 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
or coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]